Отже, що таке Qiskit?
Qiskit — це набір інструментів для розробки програмного забезпечення з відкритим кодом
для роботи з квантовими комп'ютерами
на рівні circuit
алгоритмів та модулів застосунків. Цей SDK
дозволяє будь-кому програмувати реальні квантові комп'ютери
зі свого ноутбука. Двома рядками коду ти можеш отримати доступ
до кількох квантових систем — від надпровідних
до пасткових іонних qubit. Хочеш емулювати поведінку квантового комп'ютера?
Просто зміни один рядок коду
та симулюй свої quantum circuit на нашому високопродуктивному
симуляторі. Qiskit — це інструмент, яким користуються десятки
тисяч людей по всьому світу, і всі вони прагнуть
будувати майбутнє. Незалежно від того, чи ти дослідник, розробник
або просто хочеш зробити перші кроки —
Qiskit пропонує низку
функцій для твоїх потреб,
що дозволяє будь-кому робити такі речі,
як створення свого першого quantum circuit,
запуск міждисциплінарних квантових алгоритмів
та вивчення фундаментальних квантових явищ.
Можливо, саме зараз — ідеальний час долучитися самому
та знайти всі необхідні інструменти,
включно з реальними квантовими машинами
та SDK — у Qiskit,
а також спільноту, яка із задоволенням вітає
та відповідає на будь-які запитання, що можуть виникнути на шляху.
Ти можеш почати вже сьогодні
на сайті Qiskit.